Намісник Святогірської лаври Арсеній - один із найвпливовіших архієреїв
УПЦ Московського патріархату.
Водночас 50-річний митрополит є одним із найбільш cуперечливих кліриків країни.
Він не визнає агресію Росії проти України, а війну на Донбасі відкрито називає "громадянською".
Клір його монастиря, що знаходиться на Донбасі,
у 2014 році звинувачували у підтримці бойовиків так званої "ДНР".
Разом з тим, Святогірська лавра досі надає притулок біженцям із фронтових районів.
Те, як оцінює події в Україні намісник Святогірської лаври,
віддзеркалює думку багатьох місцевих мешканців
DW вдалося поспілкуватися з митрополитом Арсенієм
і розпитати його про ставлення до ПЦУ,
російської агресії на Донбасі і президента Володимира Зеленського.
ПЦУ не щойно виникла як таке явище більш політич ного характеру, ніж церковного.
Раніше був так званий Київський патріархат.
Мене так само питали: "Чому Ви не в Київському патріархаті?"
А я людям відповідав: "А коли я Вам воду свячу, у Вас потім протухає ця свята вода?"
Кажуть: "Ні, не протухає".
Ну, якщо вода не протухає, благодаттю Духа Святого зберігається цілою і неушкодженою,
раз у мене благодать є, чого мені ще шукати?
Бо на Сьомому Вселенському соборі було таке висловлювання:
"Якщо людина, що знайшла істину, шукає ще щось - знаходить брехню".
Я знайшов істину в цій церкві і нікуди не збираюсь:
ні перефарбовуватись, в угоду тим чи іншим політикам, ні переходити.
Я в цю церкву прийшов у дитинстві і в цій церкві хрещений.
Вселенський патріархат - не Папа Римський.
Це в католицькій церкві Папа Римський один керує церквою.
У нас церква керується соборним розумом
і для вирішення складних питань збираються представники всіх 15-ти помісних церков
і вирішують те чи інше питання: чи то дарування автокефалії, чи ще якісь складні питання церкви.
Що таке Константинопольський патріархат?
Три тисячі прихожан у Туреччині і близько чотирьох мільйонів -
це Північна Америка, Європа, Канада, грецька діаспора по  всьому світу.
Це весь Константинопольський патріархат.
Приблизно там 4-5 мільйонів населення,
яке очолюється Константипольським патріархатом і його єпископами.
Ну вибачте, і у нас церкви є, чого у нас нашої думки ніхто не питає?
Як кажуть: "Самозванців нам не треба, бригадиром буду я".
Є такий, знаєте, жарт. Так і тут приблизно таке.
От сучасна проблема з біженцями, переселенцями у нас.
Розумієте - у місті Святогірськ 3,5 тисячі населення, а було 30 тисяч біженців.
Одних дітей у нас в Лаврі проживало 470.
Нам Константинопольський патріархат хоч пачку вермішелі прислав?
У нас Київський патріархат хоч буханку хліба людям дав? Ні.
Знаєте, можна по-різному розуміти тиск. Один тиск був при Сталіні.
Інший тиск був при імператорі Діоклетіані,
коли на аренах цирку християн травили звірами, наприклад, і розтинали на хрестах.
Зараз також є тиск. В якому плані тиск? Ну, всякі нісенітниці вигадують про нашу церкву.
Щось придумують, щось надумують.
Зокрема казали, що в нашому монастирі переховуються бойовики,
що у нас снайпери сидять на дзвіниці,
що ми тут переховували багатства Януковича, що я був полковником ФСБ.
Тобто засоби масової інформації, яким платили за певні теми, вони відповідно це все озвучували.
Цього нічого не було.
Я Вам такий приклад наведу.
Приїхав депутат Верховної Ради і питає: "Як Ви ставитесь до того, що Росія захопила Крим?"
Я кажу: "Так це я у Вас повинен запитати, як це Росія захопила Крим у Вас?
Воєнні бази, аеродроми, підприємства, бази відпочинку і таке інше".
По сьогоднішній день три Кримські єпархії - Сімферопольська, Джанкойська і Керченська -
перебувають у складі Української Православної Церкви.
У всіх церквах, монастирях Криму по сьогоднішній день
після патріарха Кирила поминається митрополит Онуфрій Київський і всієї України.
Вони не можуть працювати, тому що вони бояться туди їхати
Тому що, я ще раз кажу, ми є тією церквою, яка з діда-прадіда тут, розумієте?
А ця новостворена так звана церква - вона є не церквою, а організацією, це політичний проект.
І тому і поведінка у них відповідна.
Розумієте, що у нас на території Донецької області їх ніхто не празнує і до них в церкву ніхто не йде?
Ви думаєте, в Криму всі біжать до цієї ПЦУ новоствореної?
Чи в самому Донецьку чи Луганську?
Їх ніхто не празнує, до них люди не ходять.
Просто вони - ті, що свого часу були у Київському патріархаті в Донецьку -
коли ця ситуація виникла, чкурнули, кинувши свою паству, от і все.
А тепер кричать, що їх туди не пускають. Хай їдуть!
Я Вам яскравий приклад наведу, відповідаючи на це питання.
Якщо між двома країнами відбувається воєнний конфлікт,
війна і є агресія однієї з країн - вибачте,
а чого тоді у нас є посольство України в Москві і посольство Росії в Києві?
Чому через кордон їдуть автобуси: Дніпропетровськ-Москва і Волгоград-Київ?
Чому у нас частина українців, коли виникла ця ситуація, стали біженцями і побігли в Росію?
Чому у нас по сьогоднішній день залишаються економічні відносини між Україною і Росією?
Подивіться, в інтернеті зараз багато чого можна побачити. Це я не нове щось кажу.
Це внутрішній конфлікт, це громадянська війна.
Ви знаєте, війна виникає там, де не допрацьовують політики і дипломати.
І от якраз відсутність бажання почути один одного на дипломатичному рівні і спровокувало цю війну.
Один одного не хотіли почути і не хотіли йти на жодні компроміси.
А я не збираюсь нічого думати. Як я можу думати - а може це Росія, а може це Америка?
А може, це Ізраїль, а може, це Німеччина? Звідки я знаю, хто там і що там дає?
Як я це можу казати, не знаючи справжньої ситуації, хто там що і куди постачає.
Є таке прислів’я, що ворогів чи друзів ми наживаємо в процесі свого життя, а сусідів нам дає Господь Бог.
І потрібно вміти з сусідами жити, хто б вони не були - чи росіяни, чи білоруси, чи поляки.
Треба вміти налагоджувати стосунки одне з одним.
Розумієте - від того, що ми до неї добре ставимось чи погано,
Польща не візьме валізи і не переїде кудись в інше місце, звільнивши ці території.
І так само Росія не візьме валізи не переїде.
Ці держави були і залишаться на нашому кордоні, вони наші сусіди.
І тому треба якось вирішувати (конфлікти) одне з одним, вміти жити по-сусідськи.
У нас є і Нормандський формат, і Мінські домовленості.
І якщо люди підуть ще на якісь домовленості, на переговори - що ж тут поганого?
Тим більше, я вже Вам казав, що є посольство України в Москві і посольство Росії в Україні.
Нехай сідають дипломати, посли, або на рівні президентів - нехай сідають і домовляються.
Або міністри закордонних справ. Нехай вони сідають і домовляються.
Замість того, щоб говорити лозунгами і пальцем не поворухнути задля того,
щоб цю ситуацію виправити і нарешті дати людям можливість будувати своє життя,
впевненість, щоб вони бачили завтрашній день для своїх дітей і онуків,
мали забезпечену старість, робочі місця, мали, чим заплатити за комунальні послуги.
Треба сідати за стіл переговорів, домовлятися і припиняти все це.
А чого Ви не кажете, що Польща роздає у Львівській області паспорти,
а Румунія - в Чернівцях, де дві третини населення вже мають румунські паспорти?
А чого Ви не кажете, що болгари роздають в Одеській області паспорти?
Чого Ви не кажете, що угорці роздають паспорти на Закарпатті?
Просто на одному акцент роблять, а на інше закривають очі. Але це є.
Це та ситуація, коли люди не бачать стабільності і шукають якихось виходів.
Ви знаєте, для того, щоб людина сподобалась чи ні, потрібен час. Життя покаже.
Принаймні народ об’єднався у прагненні до якихось змін на краще.
Люди саме це показали своїм волевиявленням.
Вони сподіваються, що все зміниться на краще з його приходом - нової людини в політиці.
Вони обирали не зі старих політиків.
Нікому зі старих не висловили таку підтримку, як тому, хто щойно з’явився у політиці.
Нічим себе не заплямував.
Як буде далі і як його промова на інавгурації
втілюватиметься у життя, побачимо уже в процесі його президентства.
Адже Порошенка чого вибрали? Бо він сказав, що за два тижні закінчить війну. І люди повірили.
Люди вибрали Порошенка,
бо сподівались, що припиниться це безумство і ця війна з його приходом.
Люди повірили. Зараз це теж пролунало. Як буде на практиці - побачимо.
Допоможи йому Господь, тому що те, що він озвучив,
воно ніби надихає і дає надію народу, що щось зміниться на краще.
Як це буде на практиці - ми побачимо.